good to see you Frank Grillo brother how
are you buddy I'm good I'm all right now
you said you said when you sat down that
I look like I've dropped some lb strain
you look young you look healthy look at
that fit you know what your mouth looks
beautiful I appreciate you saying that
very few people have said that greatly
appreciate that but who knows who knew
years ago when you came in to talk about
Kingdom that you and I would work out in
the same gym we work out in the same gym
I've never seen their movements I've
just really started I trained yesterday
I didn't see you there nope no it was
not there as playing golf yes yes I was
just training with Randy Couture the
famous mixed martial artist yes now when
I go and work at it unbreakable I do not
train with him no I don't think he
trained with I mean the way I would say
if I could keep up with him I don't know
if I'd say I think he'd be he should be
honored to be training with me I would
yeah I would but he said oh these listen
can I train with him yesterday for the
first time you know he's Randy Couture
and then we sparred a bit and I gotta
tell you you get a peaceful because I'm
coming back today okay so I was planning
on going there today are you really yes
I am tell me what time okay well it's a
cheap gym isn't it oh gosh yeah no it's
it's got all those bells and whistles
right yeah so what what is it like
sparring with with Randy Couture's
matter it's pretty fun I mean you know
he's he's always been I've always
admired him greatly as a fighter and so
you did you never met him before you
have many people come him and I were
gonna work together a couple of times
and so I know Randy and he's a gentleman
and a scary scary man right when he
wants to be sure but it was fun we
literally trained together for two hours
that is a serious I'm in great shape I
could tell and I'm 77 years
I just thought it was that face app that
made you look this way by the way what's
up with that great question
I don't want to see that yes I don't
want to see it you say me an app that
makes you look 12 I know that what is
that stupid app exactly I don't need to
know what the hell I look like older I
don't get it I get sick do to my wife
did it now I was like don't do what what
did she did have you seen yours oh yeah
I have somebody did it to me see now my
problem Frank is for me is for some
reason I don't know what it is but the
app unquestionably makes me look twenty
years older than the oldest looking I
swear I look like I'm a hundred and
seventy-six years because for some
people but I still have my hair oddly so
oddly it didn't there's no regeneration
so if look at this on the screen right
oh my god that is so upsetting that's
not funny
there's nothing about because I get the
wrinkles and then I get I get the the
gray some people get distinguished the
app makes the look more distinguished
you something look that's imprinted in
your brain now it's imprinted in my
brain right I agree as the end is close
yeah do we have the one that is is one
of you been posted or is just bad no
it's as one of my buddies just sent it
to me but I'm not posting that no I'm
not signing up for the app either
because supposedly yes some weird thing
goes as some weird thing goes on that
suddenly somebody sitting in Russia
could break your okay into your China
I'm making little movies having a good
time we meal very good yeah
now the Kingdom era for you I imagine
exposed you to the whole fight world in
a way there's no warrior the movie I did
warrior kinda that sour is the thing
okay yeah and then Kingdom was a
byproduct of that okay yeah so who have
you met that's who haven't I met and you
know I did a show on net for it's called
fight world okay
and so that really kind of exposed me
globally to the fight community so I've
really had a great time meeting a lot of
cool people that's cool yeah so good so
Randy must have you know said I could
take this guy yeah but I'm in the circus
he's wrong he's a couple years older
than me there you go
yeah I like it that's fantastic now you
are from what's your hometown the Bronx
New York New York Dan blow up a Yankee
fan I did I'm still a Yankee fan kind of
okay yeah so what what's your first
memory of going to Yankee Stadium I went
to Yankee Stadium with my father we I
was born right next to Yankee Stadium
and I went with him when I was like 10
years old and he never took me to a
baseball game again for a football game
yeah rest asbestos oh my god you have
time we can talk about that just got off
the couch ever that have you laid down
we can go through all that now I
remember walking in the Yankee Stadium
as a kid for the first time like yeah
you know in the in the mid 70s and just
looking around and just being totally
awesome Yankee Stadium I John which is I
know set they totally they knocked it
down the new one I've been to just a
couple times I mean it's the new Yankee
Stadium right I know it it's not Yankee
Stadium did you get into the football
teams at all and oh no not really
you just ah did you New York Giants what
you've disappointed me year in and year
out except for a couple years obviously
but you know I watched the first three
games of very seasoned and like and
everybody just the rest and you tap out
yeah then I gotta watch the Patriots
that's an issue it's an issue but I have
to do it I you know what because they
constantly win and it's coming again
Frank I know itself ready everybody
thinks that Brady is gonna fall apart
not like out of the blue he's not you
know it's amazing that father time is
undefeated we hear that all the time in
sports everybody thinks that father time
is gonna creep up on Tom Brady let's
just say middle of the third quarter
week four it's not happen and it's gonna
be so Sark and it's gonna be so obvious
that it's just gonna happen it's not
happy by John Brady lives in a 60
million dollar house and in one of those
rooms father time is a
and and he has nothing it doesn't want
to bother Tom because he likes his life
there right and Tom is touched by God
he's gonna play till he looks like you
do 77 on the face you know I do like
what it's a it must be a very nice it's
probably guesthouse right now for father
time not a guest room in the pretty man
time looking at Jews Ali probably it's
discussed exactly the pool and there's
in the pool he can go it's not you've
seen his house I have not it looks like
lax its Jang it's spread out so he
doesn't even have to run into father
time around the car all the time he's
just taking care of his own thing you
keep I love that idea he's just gonna
that's the way he's gonna go in another
room is the Grim Reaper that's why he
looks ridiculous
he's gonna dominate every time I come on
we talked about him and I get nervous
yeah well I see cuz he he is he's
everything or not why would you say that
cuz he's tall he's rich he's handsome
he's married to Giselle he's the best
football player that ever lived it's all
worked you know what I mean he's super
nice you have met him or you met him yes
and he's lived to tell the day huh it's
terrible I know you didn't get let's be
honest you didn't get the invite to the
guest room so you've been him I felt
like I was like afterbirth like you know
what I mean I'm like oh that's great
that's time and then I'm Gumby tell this
story for what what season wasn't where
we 2011 a 2011 season okay he was kind
enough to agree to do a sit-down
interview for our the podcast this show
was born out of a podcast that we
started and then started televising some
of the interviews for the podcast so I'm
doing an interview with Brady and if we
were did it in New England before the
kickoff celebratory kickoff dinner for
season ticket holders or advertisers and
the players are all there so he agreed
before that he was going to come a
little early and sit down with me before
I am seed the event right
so I'm emceeing the event and you know
Kraft is
one of the biggest owners in the history
of the the league and he's invited me to
do this so I'm coming students voted but
I'm also gonna interview Tom beforehand
so I've got the best suit and I've got
the whole like three-piece I got a
sweater underneath it's a Zegna suit Wow
rush it Brady walks in the room and I
felt like I was wearing a burlap sack
it's the worst to shot the most
undefeated to shot of my career it's
terrible man I know arrabal that he
exists frank grillo here on the Rich
Eisen show let's talk about into the
ashes we just saw a clip of that folks
tell everybody what this film is it's a
little film it so it's really a little
independent movie which you know you you
kind of want to keep making these movies
because if you don't these filmmakers
they fall through the cracks because
they're Marvel and all these great big
giant movies that we all go to see yes
and it's kind of like No Country for Old
Men in the vein of a simple kind of
revenge Darkman war and i play once
again the psychotic the psychotic who
who actually the good guy isn't so good
and the bad guy has reason to be a bad
guy okay this one so it's it's a funny
you know I don't know that it's fun it's
it's a cool little flick and it's an
limited release and then a little stream
at the same time and yeah I like doing
these I like doing these these little
these little movies like this that's
great yeah and why do people keep making
you a bad guy yeah what's up with that
no I think there's something inside me
is because I got nothing else okay I'm
the Tom Brady of movies and then point
blank this is amazing cast that you are
here with I made that move I produced it
My partner and I Joe Carnahan well
congratulations on that it's fine we got
to put it all together and hired Macke
and Marcia Gay Harden and you know it's
some people like it and some critics are
like well it's we've seen this before
I'm like well what do you want me to
tell you what am i by the way I would
pay to have you retort to critics on by
the way my agents say do not do
like I'm calling New York Times because
listen they want to kill the business
like it's movie you you just they're
just gonna want to review either Oscar
movies or giant Marvel movies well not
just what I mean is I wouldn't pay to
see you criticize critics for your work
I'm like you you would be hired by
anybody that's a call a critic of like
safe for me from my show to be my proxy
to call the crit and I would do it and I
have good questions for them you know
yes starting with what the hell right
what the hell critic come to unbreakable
performance that's right let me critique
Marcia Gay Harden Anthony Mackie who's a
big Saints fan yes he is diehard he
lives in New Orleans he's a New Orleans
Saints fan he's a big boy down now he
must have been really pissed about the
anaphora ship that holes I was doing a
movie there for Sony when that happened
and that the city just went crazy
there's still nuts about it they they
they were like we're not watching the
Superbowl we're right at work we're
gonna have parades so no one watches the
Superbowl come to the parade they were
showing old football of games of the of
the Saints it was it was bananas
yeah they brockman if I'm not mistaken
for Fat Tuesday a bunch were dressed up
as referees behind red line referee and
crazy
it was crazy they were afraid they were
gonna be like riots well I mean and now
they've changed the rules to make
instant replay reviewable right based on
a lot of all that yeah how come you're
not on social media Frank I'm on
Instagram are you on Instagram yeah
Frank Grillo won I think that Frank
Grillo won on Instagram but no Twitter
for you huh no I feel like they're mean
on Twitter by the way I'm very sensitive
you're right you're right you're spot-on
yeah I don't need that I Drive enough
anxiety in my life you do have by the
way you have like a 12-pack in your
Instagram profile I do over 12-pack by
the way geez
I have that why you from Brady doesn't
have a 12-pack he's soft
well he's a bit soft for why are you
from frank grillo one it was there Frank
really it was what the hell
just use the Frank he's a teacher from
come on yeah from like Milwaukee
is something he's got his own Instagram
even that I gotta be my own Instagram
the 12-pack should should Trump right it
should just Trump whoever's got the guy
the guy who's that frank grillo yeah
what does he look like his profile photo
is the da he's got the dog ears filter
on it I mean that's gotta make it worse
you're gonna balk Frank that's gonna
make that's Frank Grillo I'm really not
a psycho I'm Frank Grillo what how many
people will just say I'm a big fan of
Frank Grillo let me go on Instagram and
see what's going on they see the dog
your dad this guy's got some Jim photos
Franco's your match with this kid Shh
I'll take my shirt off right now into
the ashes in theaters on digital and
on-demand starting tomorrow
Point Blank has been on Netflix produced
and also stuff with with my guy right
here Frank Grillo you produced that
great cast man like I said super stuff
good to see you brother Oh any time
please this is like 12 movies coming out
this year so okay yeah one of them must
do well one minutes just odds love
average right one of them you've got
according to our check cuz we always
check the IMDB you've got eight movies
in production yeah eight right now I
only make $7 man's making $56 which
means a hell of a jacket yeah good to
see you right there just yet Frank
Grillo one do not mistake him with Frank
Grillo for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app